and speaking of school how about more
than the annual back to school driving
basics
of course you should be prepared not
only for the first days of flashing
lights around schools but also for the
increased presence of law enforcement
and maybe keep that mindset even when
police may not be there
a quick note from the school district
all campuses will have changes in
traffic flow to enforce that new rule
about single point of entry
and many schools have new fencing that
might affect you and your kiddo and
while the ccsd may not be the biggest
school district in the country they tell
us they do have the biggest owned and
operated school bus fleet in the nation
as we just heard from christian concerts
now they tell us they are 60 percent
done upgrading the cameras that are
already on board the district's nearly 2
000 buses buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone you can join
the drive in you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eight news now dot com